so look we're getting all this vaccine
mandate stuff and if you turn on any
news channel there's no debate
about whether we should have mandates or
not there's very little debate about
whether we should have uh vaccines or
not you know whether your health and
your age and your the foods that you eat
and the medicines and supplements that
you take whether any of those things
should affect whether you need to take
the vaccine or not it's all just take
take take take every channel is just
take the vaccine mandates are good
there's almost no pushback we have
ridiculous civil rights lawyers like
gloria allred who i debated a couple
weeks ago if you haven't seen it it's on
our youtube channel who are saying this
is not about rights i mean we're just
not even debating the basic things that
used to be like absolute truths that
civil rights matter individual rights
matter
and if you wonder why if you've been
sitting there going you know something
doesn't seem right to me why is it that
these shows every cbs and nbc and
abc show they all keep pushing these
vaccines
well this is just spectacular who did
this i want to credit them properly
because it's actually just wonderful at
underscore whitney webb two bees
tweeted out this video it's a
compilation from some of your favorite
uh news programs take a look good
morning america is brought to you by
pfizer cbs health watch sponsored by
pfizer anderson cooper 360.
brought to you by pfizer abc news
nightline brought to you by pfizer
making a difference
brought to you by pfizer cnn tonight
brought to you by pfizer early start
brought to you by pfizer friday night on
aaron burnett out front brought to you
by pfizer this week with george
stephanopoulos is brought to you by
pfizer this weather report brought to
you by pfizer today's countdown to the
royal wedding is brought to you by
pfizer and now a cbs sports update
brought to you by pfizer meet the press
data download brought to you by pfizer
this portion of cbs this morning
sponsored by pfizer on how to find the
hidden sugars in the american family
diet sponsored by pfizer
must i add anything else
i'm dave rubin this has been the reuben
report
not brought to you
by pfizer